hello freak [ __ ] isn't there also an
issue with our incredibly limited
ability to view reality itself because
we're only viewing the dimensions that
are relevant to us in this current state
of carbon-based life form it's Kurt this
this talking monkey cling to the
spaceship flying through the universe
this is this is what's important to us
but when you pay attention to those
dudes who write on yellow legal pads
they get into quantum physics and they
have all those crazy equations that
nobody but them understands maybe you do
I look at that [ __ ] I go what the [ __ ]
are they writing but they believe I mean
what is the current model they believe
there's at least 11 dimensions or
perhaps could be more what if there is
dimension that you can plug into that
it's purely consciousness driven meaning
there's no physical experience there's
no touching the ground there's no
gravity but you exist in a conscious
state and it's perpetual like if you
take a rocket ship and it gets past our
gravity and shoots off into distant
space and you have a clear shot of you
know 14 billion years back to the
beginning of the universe itself with
nothing in the way you're just going to
keep going for 14 billion light years
you're just going to keep going like
what if there is a place that your
consciousness can go to like that where
can't it's no longer burdened by biology
by the timeline of birth to death by the
limitations of the flesh but
consciousness itself can exist in some
bizarre dimension that we just haven't
access to so yeah I mean I think
consciousness is probably just
ultimately a physical process I think
that in ultimately because of
conservation of energy
the reason being so you know this is oh
yeah age-old philosophical debate
between the monists and dualists people
who think is consciousness just
ultimately some sort of physical process
or is it something special so Descartes
thought there was this penny I'll grant
glands this little bit of your brain and
your conscious kind of soul was just
kind of steering you're like monkey body
through this pineal gland
but the question is just for why that I
think the strongest argument about why
that couldn't be right is it seems to be
like it would have to be creating energy
out of nowhere and we've never it seems
to be just fixed law of the universe but
that just can't happen because in order
for you know this conscious mind to if
it's not merely a physical process if
it's not just the brain in order for it
to be able to affect what this physical
entity is doing it would have to use
energy to be able to do that so the
energy will have to be coming from
somewhere and if it's not coming from
just the physical realm then suddenly we
got this council example to all the rest
of science sort of but are you aware of
the theories of human neurotransmitters
being pathways to other dimensions like
dimethyltryptamine do you know about all
that um I mean I know about DMT you know
I think it is from the pineal gland
where Descartes thought that all that
stuff was going on the seat of the soul
with the Egyptians called the Eye of
Horus the reason why the Catholics and
so many ancient religions were so
focused on pinecones and their their art
and their their imagery that's the
pineal gland like that that's the the
image of it that's what ya chose to
represent and for people who've had
these intense transformative psychedelic
experiences by consuming exogenous
dimethyltryptamine which is produced by
the brain that you have these insane
transformative experiences where you
feel like you are traveling to other
dimension yeah so I think I mean I do
want to say like have you done any of
that I've never done DMT Oh son of a
[ __ ] why not what are you doing wasting
your time I know if it's a good boy haha
but but it's something that's in the
brain I mean it's a natural product of
human biology I mean whether its natural
or not the question just you know if I'm
going to have a career based on my brain
I want to be very careful to to not
break it not like it yeah yeah but it's
one of the most transient drugs ever
observed in the body but it brings it
back to baseline in like 15 minutes hmm
okay is that because I mean there's a
lot I do think there's like tons of
people very often greatly overestimate
risk social norm illegal drugs like MDMA
is like super safe and so on very over
overestimates a list
the risk of everything yet of MDMA yeah
yeah
MDMA is weird right that's a weird one
it's not a natural drug
dimethyltryptamine I think the real
concern would be psychological because
what you face is so bizarre turns from
Crenna McKenna had the best quote about
it I think he said that you would risk
death by astonishment hmm yeah okay so
the thing well maybe it's so bizarre
that it's almost a sin for a guy as
smart as you to not experience it but
you just come right back in your you
even when you're there you're there make
at you it's not like you your
consciousness dissolves into some
bizarre quasi living State and they have
to like work your way back to being you
again now you're you your will McCaskill
in the dimension whatever the [ __ ] it is
but what's crazy about it is that this
is produced in the very area where
Descartes was believing the seat of the
soul is and so many different Eastern
religions and all this psychological
like all these different all these
different religions and all these
different cultures they were all
convinced that that one gland had some
massive significance in terms of the
spirit in the soul whatever that means
whatever spirit means so yeah so then
the question is just in these
experiences is it the case that you're
like seeing into genuinely seeing into
another dimension right or is it the
case that you have a new kind of
perspective on consciousness so one
thing I do think is that in terms of
conscious experience is the sort of
conscious experiences that humans have
access to and I think that must just be
point zero zero one percent of the
entire landscape of possible conscious
experiences hmm so if you think imagine
if you have a bat and you could
echolocate hmm that's just a radically
different conscious experience I don't
think that map's under any sort of
conscious experience that humans could
have have you seen people do that I know
there are people young people can do
that it's pretty amazing that is it is
amazing to shockingly effectively yeah I
think you're absolutely right I mean but
there's also experiences human
experiences that are available without
drugs that some people have achieved
through radical states of meditation
Kundalini Yoga where they could achieve
natural psychedelic state holotropic
breathing people that have done that as
experience like really radical
psychological transformations and
incredible psychedelic experiences when
out as well yeah and so I think like
these sorts of experiences are very
important very interesting and what
they're you know I said that maybe we
experience was point zero one percent of
all possible conscious experience ISM it
just allows you to do like see a little
bit more of this potential vast
landscape well as I think but I think
there's nothing unmagical about saying
ultimately that's all explained in terms
of physics in terms of different sources
new lands filing and different moments
of power transmitters and so on we don't
need to say oh and it's also this other
thing which breaks all the known laws of
physics that you're seeing into some
other dimension in order for that to be
an incredibly important thing an order
that unscientific to say we know almost
nothing about consciousness in terms of
the areas of scientific inquiry we have
no understanding at all about the
relationship between conscious
experiences and you know what we would
think of as physical processes we would
really have no idea about you know if
you take give me any sufficiently
complicated physical processes which are
which are conscious and which are not
all we can go on is really this well I'm
conscious and so I know that things that
kind of like me are probably conscious
too and that's the best we've got really
and this is known as a hard problem of
consciousness and swathers often say a
solved it with something and I think
it's always begging the question I think
we should be very open to the fact that
just as in you know 3,000 BC people had
no idea about the laws of physics this
was just completely unexplored territory
we should think contemporary science
this is just a big like big black gap in
a scientific understanding and perhaps
it's something maybe 21st century
science between iron century science can
we get to grips with yeah it does seem
like the ultimate question like what is
it for
why is it here what controls it is it in
the mind is it external is the brain
just an antenna that tunes into
consciousness the the dimethyltryptamine
question is so bizarre because it's the
most potent psychedelic drug known to
man and your brain makes it yeah what
I've been there for I don't know if this
is a myth I said it's what gets made
when you die
yeah that's they believe that during
high rates of stress we body believed
you're going to die and when you're
dreaming when you're in heavy REM sleep
your body produces larger amounts of it
then instead then baseline but they
don't know it's it's really difficult
they've only just now within the last
few years the Cottonwood Research
Foundation which dr. Rick Strassman has
a big part of it he's the guy who wrote
the book DMT the spirit molecule he did
a bunch of the first fda-approved drug
trials with civilians where they took
people and they gave them a Schedule one
drug
dimethyltryptamine which is so crazy
that it's a Schedule one drug that your
body produces but they gave it to people
intravenously over the course of several
months and they documented all the
different trips and all the different
the different commonalities that these
people had in their experiences and he's
working very closely with the Cottonwood
Research Foundation and one of the
things that they found is that they've
recently discovered it was just
anecdotal evidence that was produced by
the pineal gland we knew that DMT was
produced by the liver and the lungs but
now they know for sure because they've
isolated it in rats
so in living rats they know that they
produce DMT with the pineal gland so
that that explains a lot of you know
ancient Eastern mysticism and all the
symbology this all these symbols that
people had to represent this this gland
now they know okay well this gland
definitely does produce this incredibly
potent psychedelic drug but now the
cross the question is at what levels
during what periods of stress like how
do you have to bring someone to the
point of death before they experience
this and if that is the case is it
possible that consciousness itself is
something that we you know
we haven't really figured out what
exactly it is is it possible that
consciousness can travel through this
chemical pathway that maybe these
intense dimethyltryptamine experiences
are in fact a gateway to what people
have assumed exists from the beginning
of time like an afterlife or a sea of
souls or something some some stage of
existence other than this physical
existence that we all experience right
now yeah so I mean I feel like I'd be
like crazy talk right it sounds like
they see it's coming out of my mouth I'm
going what the [ __ ] are you talking
about dude and I mean I think I'd just
be surprised if consciousness was just
as one chemical I think it's much more
likely that something is this emergent
phenomena from this incredibly complex
system of you know billions of different
neurons filing in a certain way and when
you have a certain process it's
sufficiently complex in the right way
somehow and this is just this big black
box that we've got no idea about somehow
subjective experience comes out of that
but it would seem I mean otherwise the
issue is you could have just DMT
traveling and just a test tube or
something and petri dish and it would
seem like oh is this petri dish
conscious that would seem really strange
why would that be the case if you're
breathing air and you're you know the
air keeps you alive like you're
breathing and bringing out you don't
think that air carries the life with it
to another place right air is just a
component of life yeah something that
your body requires yeah so I mean it's
possible maybe it's the case so again I
feel like be surprised if it's like this
chemical is necessary for consciousness
in some way I'm not saying it's
necessary but I am curious as to how
consciousness varies
you know consciousness consciousness and
you you the actual feeling of being
alive varies depending upon your health
is it depending upon stress levels
depending upon love and happiness and
all these different factors change the
way you view the world which is really
interesting because in effect that
changes consciousness and you can be
more you know you can be more elevated
like you can guarantee you all this
effective altruism that you're
concentrating on is somehow another
elevating your consciousness because
you're putting out so much love
and so much happiness and you're helping
so many people there's so many positive
benefits to your very existence I've got
to manage I've got to believe rather
that's somehow another that manages to
come back to you I mean it definitely
comes back to me in kind of how I feel
about my life I mean when we're talking
about how money is just not the key to a
happy life the question is well what is
and the answers are having a great
community having a greater purpose in
life when I'm feeling like you're making
a difference so all of these reasons are
why so we built up as can a community
around effective altruism people all
around the world who are making a
significant change so for example
donating 10% of them income come to the
Potala tees they think most effective or
pursuing a Clio that we think is really
effective and one thing I wasn't
surprising from the outset that I'm so
happy happened is that the strong
community has formed kind of like a
little global village or something and
people have found for actually far from
being a sacrifice as you might have
expected this is actually incredibly
rewarding because you've now got this
community of people who have shared aims
to you and you're all working towards
this greater goal and that's something
that Inc is very lacking in the world
today lo so many people just they work
9:00 to 5:00 and you know they have a
nice time on the weekend but they're
like where is all of this going and of
my life am I really going to think yeah
I made the most of this whereas if you
think at the end of your life like yep I
dedicated my life to helping others and
I had this transformative impact on
thousands of people you're not going to
think at the end of your life gee I
really wasted that right it's just
something I don't think you can really
look that if you go deep though down the
philosophical rabbit hole and you really
consider that life is this temporary
experience and even benefiting someone
through this temporary experience is
still a temporary experience it's like
you are helping someone you gave them a
pillow for the ride and it's a temporary
ride the ride comes to an end and then
what and then what is the point of all
this like what is the point of effective
altruism if you're just helping people
during this temporary
I'd it doesn't seem to mean anything
yeah so I think there's two things I
like your I posed just can't help myself
I can do it to you just raise up I just
don't want the [ __ ] isn't a bit freaked
myself out well we do get freaked out at
this what you know when you think of
cause I can central and yeah so angst of
existence so I think the two I think
it's two answers here okay the first is
that the right is the like goal right
ultimately again if you think the
purpose of life is to increase the
amount of happiness and reduce the
amount of suffering the final goal is
good experiences and the kind of anti
goal as bad experiences so when we're
sitting here talking having a great time
this is us kind of achieving those gang
points in the wind encounter so we have
a good time that's what yeah if we were
really hating this then we'd be losing
well even more so because we're
broadcasting this live and millions of
people are going to hear it yeah and
hopefully that having hopefully that
enjoying hopefully and maybe of they're
not at least it was a little stress
relief like maybe they're at the gym and
I go these [ __ ] idiots II haven't
haven't squats and they're getting angry
yeah so I think that's the first thing
but then the second thing is relates to
this idea of cosmic significance where
what often motivate csail were just
along for a ride we're all going to get
eaten up by the Sun eventually and so on
what's the kind of greater purpose of
life but I actually think there are some
ways that our actions now can have much
greater cosmic significance and that's
if that's because I think if you think
that the human race survives for the
next few centuries it seems kind of
inevitable look we're going to spread to
the Stars and I think that would be good
again from this perspective go into more
arguments if you want of just saying
what we want to do is promote happiness
and we do suffering if that means we can
live on other planets as well and have
kind of rising civilizations they're not
only where the people are having great
lies but also making scientific artistic
contributions and so on then that's a
good thing to do as well
well there's no technological reason for
thinking that we won't be able to do
that in the future given current rates
of technological progress unless
something really bad happens along the
way and this kind of gets back to one of
the things we talked about right we'll
start was one of the focus areas of
effective altars and community is on
kind of tryna reduce risks from human
extinction of global catastrophic risks
these are the sorts of things that could
imperil the human journey as it were and
I think that if you're working to
mitigate some of these things then
you're increasing the chance that we do
get to the sort of level where you yeah
humanity can have a fiving future not
just on this planet but on other planets
as well and that actually means your
actions really do have this huge cosmic
significance so the conscious effort to
be a kind person a generous person and
effective altruism spreads and it
impacts people there's this ripple
effect and your good deeds could perhaps
fuel enough people with this thought and
with effective altruism and more people
might act on that to the point where we
reduce the amount of suffering to the
point where we extend the lifespan of
human beings we extend the areas where
we have no war we reduce the amount of
violence to the point where we can
successfully innovate to the point where
we can get off this planet that's not
and then start from scratch with a new
dictator on Mars Donald Trump on Mars
how about that yeah I mean so I think of
a Boonton on Mars
well he's become president of Mars I'd
be pretty happy with that be fascinating
if we'd have to go to war with Mars
[Applause]
[Music]